cheikh combattant au crochet puis sont
ou pas le temps d ways les mis ko c'est
fini si je vous dis mma vous pensez à
mana et non et si on ne parle pas
d'assurance auto mais d'arts martiaux
mixtes les mixed martial art en anglais
une discipline longtemps interdite en
france
car jugée trop violente selon certains
notamment l'ancien secrétaire d'état aux
sports thierry braillard pour qu'il
s'agit de jeux de cirque
[Musique]
ce sport de combat mise en valeur par
l'irlandais à mcgregor ou leurs
enseignants magomedov vient d'être
autorisé en france
pourquoi la boxe on partait de ce sport
pourquoi l'état légaliste il une
discipline qui compte entre 30000 et
50000 pratiquante sur la commission
française de mma nouvel eldorado
économique ou enjeu de santé publique
on en parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france pour un nouveau
numéro de l'autre match le mois dernier
la ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu a annoncé son intention de
légaliser le mma
le mixed martial art en anglais la
fédération de tutelle la fédération
française de boxe
pourquoi quels enjeux sur la société on
en parle avec nos invités
fernand lopez sur ce plateau à fondateur
et directeur du mma factory
l'entraînement le plus coté en france
des arts martiaux mixtes et puis à vos
côtés jean philippe lustyk la voie de la
boxe en france sur l'équipe et 24 news
notamment et auteur du grand livre de la
boxe aux éditions marabout bonjour
messieurs bienvenue sur sur ce plateau
bonjour à vous tous avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet on a posé cette
question aux internautes sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ayrté france sur environ 2700
vote
et cette question est même à légaliser
enjeu de santé publique
oui à 33% 67% en ont un jeu de santé
publique le mma légaliser fernand lopez
selon vous je pense que oui et pourquoi
parce que ce serait irresponsable de
laisser à un peu plus de 50000 français
pratiquer un sport de manière sauvage
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on encadre le
sport il fallait qu'on l'encadrent qu'on
évite d'élaguer rive-sud la pratique
sauvage qu'on évite qu'on apporte ce
qu'on appelle l'obligation de
qualification qui existent dans tous les
autres sports
l'article 212 du code du sport oblige
toute personne qui veut enseigner
éduquer
dans toute discipline sportive à être
qualifié pour pouvoir comprendre les
compétences sur la biomécanique la
physiologie je suis au corps et donc
c'est une bonne chose de ne pas dans
l'idée que vous pensez je pense
qu'effectivement ça danger de santé de
protéger l'accès physique des pratiques
en donnant votre avis jean philippe
lustyk par rapport à cet enjeu public
cet enjeu de santé publique par rapport
à ça me semble indispensable parce qu'il
a tellement été critiqués on évoquera
certainement durant nos échanges mais la
qualité critiqué ce sport là pour des
raisons dont je visite éventuelle donc
l'encadrement était indispensable
puisque comme il le précise le principal
c'est la priorité l'obsession c'est la
santé des pratiquants c'est donc
d'encadrer il doit permettre de pouvoir
s'épanouir dans toutes les situations
dans tous les clubs avec le maximum de
sécurité comme la boxe l'est donc oui
c'est un enjeu capital
alors pourquoi pourquoi
il ya plus de personnes qui répondent
non selon vous je pense qu'on est dans
un monde où on a peur du nouveau de ce
qui est nouveau de ce qui est connu
j'aime souvent dire que les phases de de
la vie des nouveautés passe pas failli à
trois phases i à la la partie au cc non
c'est une folie c'est inadmissible et
puis à la partie où c'est dangereux pour
l'ordre établi et puis on termine
souvent par l'évidence on s'est dit
c'est utiliser évident et je pense que
le web a suivit ce bac ou la com com le
full contact et un dépôt comme la boxe
thaï
à une époque qui était finalement ça
devient une évidence aujourd'hui pour la
ministre des sports a mis sous tutelle
de deux voulant car cette discipline
alors on l'a dit on encadre via la box
qui est la fédération de tutelle du mma
pourquoi la boxe est donc au-delà du
pourquoi la boxe pourquoi l'encadré est
ce que c'est pour savoir vers qui se
retourner si jamais il ya quelque chose
de grave un problème grave voire une
mort éventuellement non alors attention
parce que attention aux mots il faut
être prudent dans la situation actuelle
parce que ce n'est pas la fédération
française de boxe qui va organiser à ce
jour l'organisation et structuré donc
pour l'instant il y a comme un déjeuner
j'ai envie de dire un essai donc il y a
la volonté incontestable du ministère
d'encadrer ce sport et la fédération
française de boxe a gagné l'appel
d'offres en quelque sorte un jour qu'il
y avait la lutte exactement jadot et
judo voilà qui était en concurrence
entre la bourse française entre parents
voilà et donc c'est par le biais de la
structure de la fédération française de
boxe qu'on va justement encadré
structure est à la fois sur un plan
amateurs et professionnels cette
nouvelle discipline dite sauvage entre
guillemets qui est le même à met donc à
tous les niveaux parce que pas juste au
niveau professionnel et plus grandes
compétitions les plus prestigieuses mais
également les pratiquants c'est cela
donc on met en place la fédération
l'occurrence d'un mettre en place alors
donc c'est la structure sur un plan
médical l'organisation les compétitions
qui entraîne qui est diplômé qui ne le
sera pas vain il y a un énorme travail
en profondeur qui est fait et c'est
l'expérience le vécu de la fédération
française de
boxe qui a la foi et pertinentes dans le
monde amateur et professionnel qui est
chargée de cette lourde mission est ce
qu'après un côté hypocrite quand même de
légaliser le mma sachant qu'il y avait
déjà des pratiques on vous l'avait dit
un peu plus de 50000 les chiffres
varient selon la commission française du
mma c'est entre 30000 et 50000 voilà
grosso modo en tous les cas il ya
beaucoup de pratiquants est ce qu'il ya
un côté hypocrite de légaliser sachant
qu'il ya déjà des pratiquants
c'est pour ça que je parle pas de
l'égalisation je parle de normalisation
je parle de reconnaissance
éventuellement mais pas de l'égalisation
le manager était illégale
le mma se pratique en france depuis une
trentaine d'années la compétition du
même dieu mais ma n'était même pas
illégal elle est devenue illégale en
2015 hulu il ya trois ans en septembre
on a organisé un événement j'ai co
organiser un événement aussi divers le
premier événement est le seul événement
de même avec une cage avec des frappes
au sol dans le rouge non seulement à
paris en octobre rennes comme on voit
derrière dr
il y avait pas l'appellation anemasse et
ça s'était appelé à mes mains c'est
clairement un moment et il se trouve que
après il ya un vide juridique et après
ça le s'inquiéter et à l'éducation
monsieur brian décidé de modifier le
texte de loi sur le code du sport
justement pour pouvoir d'une bonne foi
interdit la compétition mais en aucun
cas le mma a été illégale alors vous
parlez de thierry braillard dans un
article qui vous est consacré dans
libération thierry braillard parle donc
l'ancien secrétaire d'état aux sports et
considère le mma je cite comme une
émanation moderne des jeux de cirque
qu'est ce que
ça vous fait d'entendre ça encore une
fois de plus ça n'engage que lui je
comprends qu'on ait des commentaires des
appréciations différentes de ce qui est
le sport
je respecte son point de vue mais on est
très loin de ça la preuve c'est que
monsieur brian n'a pas fait la recherche
confesse ses collègues
aujourd'hui on à madame leur aspect
celle qui a fait la démarche d'aller au
canada d'aller se confronter au
ministère des sports canadiens
comprendre comment on gère lui-même
annaba leur adresser à l'ancien ministre
et ancien ministre des sports ensuite
juste avant qu'elle ne s'en aille elle a
laissé ce dossier à colette qui arrivait
madame a ici un homme
roxana la nouvelle ministre l'action
ministre a fait la même démarche
d'ailleurs madame laura flessel est
passé dans ma salle ou mma factory elle
était elle avait demandé à ce que son
cabinet et réserves quand cinq minutes
elle a fait 3 heures ou mma factory a
essayé de comprendre comment fonctionne
le modèle économique d'une salle commune
à la factory a essayé de comprendre
comment fonctionne comment on entraîne
les jeunes les enfants puisque on a une
section de près de 150 enfants et de la
factory
elle a regardé les professionnels
s'entraîner madame roxana maracineanu
elle a fait la même chose trois heures
sur le terrain ça c'est le devoir et la
responsabilité d'un ministre de tutelle
d'essayer de comprendre déjà ce qui se
passe elle a analysé avec ses collègues
avec les loisirs cap avec les collègues
les personnes qui étaient là pour pour
arriver à un plan concret et se dire
cette discipline existe c'est vraiment
du sport et et là on peut avancer des
déclarations la première déclaration
qu'il avance monsieur drâa c'est le mma
illégal effectivement il se retrouve
face à une situation compliquée ce
qu'ils ont réussi à organiser l'onema
par le biais de l'afp la préfecture avec
une autorisation normal
et là il se retrouve avec une différence
de postures kg mais mal à l'aise il va
continuer à s'enfoncer
le mma du cou qui devient normalisé si
on utilise vos termes fernand lopez quel
impact ça va avoir sur la société est ce
que la société va être moins violente
parce que du coup les gens se trompent
et est de canaliser ou est ce que la
société mène plus violente parce que ça
va donner
vie certains de vouloir faire dans des
lieux non sécurisées chloride non mais
je pense que ça serait utopique
d'imaginer que le débat va résoudre les
problèmes de violence société j'aimerais
comme la boxe pourrait résoudre non si
elle peut apaiser atténuer ça serait
déjà formidable résoudre c'est violent
ce nom après ce elle peut permettre et
c'est important à ces jeunes là qu'ils
ont cette énergie pour ne pas dire
d'autre pourquoi utiliser d'autres
termes qui ont besoin de se dépenser
dans un espace réglementés de pouvoir
s'épanouir et de pouvoir je dirais
lâcher cette agressivité cette haine
qu'ils peuvent avoir
ça c'est formidable dans le cadre
justement réglementaire avec des
entraîneurs de qualité et qui savent
voir qu'ils savent échanger et qui
savent créer un lien très fort avec ses
pratiquants maintenant l'histoire sur la
société mais l'histoire de l'humanité
montre que les jeux du cirque ont
fasciné pendant 1500 ans puisque les
jeux olympiques ont été créés les
premiers en moins 776 moi j'écris je
crois jusqu'en 396 vous imaginez donc
sur mille ans d'histoire et il y avait
les fameux jeux du cirque où il y avait
le pancrace où il y avait ces
disciplines qui était l'ancêtre de la
boxe ou la mort était souvent au rendez
vous donc ensuite au fur et à mesure le
temps a permis d'atténuer d'humaniser le
sport je pense que le mma a souffert et
souffrent de moins en moins de son image
première qui remonte à une trentaine
d'années lorsqu'elle n'est pas encadrée
lorsque les accidents le fait d dans un
octogone dans cette arène fermée un peu
choquant pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas ou il ya eu beaucoup de coups de
coude
beaucoup de violence et donc ça a pu
choquer mais est-ce que c'est plus
violent par exemple que la boxe vous qui
faites
la boxe qui commentent et beaucoup de
combats de boxe
est-ce que c'est plus violent est ce que
c'est plus violente le karaté est ce que
c'est plus violent que le kung fu le ju
jitsu brésilien je sais pas de toutes
les arts martiaux la alors en terme
d'accidents il ya pas plus d'accidents
si on calcule le nombre de décès dans
les compétitions en uf6 y en a eu un ou
deux je crois dans les années 93 94
comme en boxe il ya des accidents qui
sont mortels mais qui se sont un infime
pourcentage par rapport au nombre de
pratiquants mais ce sport là au début on
est exactement dans la même aventure que
la boxe a connu à la fin du dix septième
siècle lorsque la boxe est créé dans les
années 780 jusqu'à 10 730 allait pas
codifié où tout est permis pas de
catégories de toi c'est ce qui s'est
passé pas de catégorie de poids pas de
rennes où peu de règles pas de durée de
match sauf que l'espace temps et a été
bien plus long que ce qu'a vécu le mma
qui apparaît il ya 30 35 ans qui est une
très courte histoire et rapidement pour
pouvoir s'installer dans la société on
n'en cabre on protège et on instaure des
rings on instaure des minutes décomptées
une durée des catégories de poids enfin
voilà donc mais c'est quoi l'esprit
c'est quoi les codes du mma parce que
vous venez de le dire il ya des
catégories de poids en boxe on dit que
c'est un sport de gentlemen le même
assez peu ses codes je souhaite revenir
une chose est ce qu'il aurait même et
violent hui il est violent parce que
l'essence même de la violence ça
commence à partir du moment où une
opposition physique quel que soit le
sport le judo la boxe au karaté j'ai
doivent prendre la vente sur vos de
manière physique ou cognitives je
deviens il ya de la violence au hockey
est-ce qu'il est plus violent comme une
chose pour le combat j'ai dit non il
faudrait me le prouver ça va être très
compliqué à trouver maintenant quelles
sont les valeurs
je pense que les valeurs du mma sont les
mêmes que la plupart des sports le fait
appeler la déontologie l'éthique le
le respect ce sont des valeurs qu'on
partage qu'on lui qu'on voit tous les
jours ceux qui suivent le même
aujourd'hui le savent depuis une
trentaine d'années lui-même a évolué
comme tous les sports aujourd'hui le
football continue à évoluer le rugby
évolue on parle l'abitrage qui passe de
norma l'abitrage vidéo et les rayons
évolué sur le mma aujourd'hui on a une
épine sportive avec une logique interne
avec un espace délimité avec un temps
limité avec des règles des défenses
c'est avec une vraie un vrai système un
vrai programme probablement le plus
performant de tous sports confondus
le programme antidopage de dieu même ans
aujourd'hui en tout cas sous ses pieds
la grosse compétition comme lui aussi
avec le le programme usada donc
aujourd'hui on cfc pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas
shipp si la ligue des champions voilà on
va tous des champions de la compétition
ça en foot voilà une des champions et le
fcc la compétition majeure quand on est
champion ufc mais c'est la fin du
premier round quand on reste sur le ring
sur le togo n'est on revient dans un
instant pour continuer de parler d'eux
mêmes a tout de suite
de retour sur le plateau de l'autre
match est spécial mm à nos invités sont
toujours présents à fernand lopez
directeur et fondateur du mma factory et
jean philippe lustyk hauteur du grand
livre de la boxe aux éditions un
marabout à monsieur on était en train de
parler notamment de la violence du mma
vous vouliez dire quelque chose à ce
sujet jean philippe oui parce que ce qui
a choqué ce qui choque encore dans les
mémoires
c'est sa relative complexité lorsqu'on
parle de boxe deux adversaires utilisent
leur poids il ya trois coups directs le
crochet enfin je schématise c'est simple
on essaie de mettre l'adversaire et
admire lorsque l'on est dans cet
octogone cet espace qui peut déranger
à première vue par rapport au ring comme
le ring d'ailleurs après a dérangé mais
c'est un mélange de beaucoup de
discipline mais on parle de jci dessus
on parle du grappling on parle du
pancrace la lutte et on a du mal à
comprendre dont il est comme on voit
beaucoup de séquences à la fois de la
boxe on utilise les pieds on utilise les
coudes on utilise ont comme au rugby on
fait un plaquage aux jambes
on va utiliser les coups de coude donc
appris à ce travail au sol qui parfois
est invisible et et donc il ya des
images qui dérange parce qu'on n'est pas
habitué à voir autant de disciplines
réunissent cet espace-là salomon
habitudes oui mais tout se joue dessus
dans ces nouveaux on a tendance à moi je
regarde la tauromachie la première fois
je verrai années j'étais extrêmement
choquée parce que c'est relatif alors
que celui qui a grandi dans le village
de 2 voilà où ça se passe il n'y a pas
de problème cgc relative tout le temps
de voir un coup de pub de matériaux est
sûre ça me choque parce qu'on sort du
cadre des règles établies on n'est pas
dans la logique interne du football et
donc c'est très relatif
cependant je suis comme je comprends je
comprends que les personnes il y aura
une phase d'éducation on va le voir
prendre le temps d'évangéliser d'éduquer
la population dessus justement vous
parler d'éducation vous parliez tout à
l'heure de jeunes vous avez dit 150
gène dans votre école comment expliquer
que tant de jeunes s'intéressent aux mma
et peut-être au détriment d'autres
fédérations peut-être avec le judo ça
fait polémique le mma qui passe dans le
giron de la boxe est fait dans le judo
sincèrement avec toute objectivité je
veux parler d'eux de du rapport du
continuum entre le sparta stable et
instable en gros je pense que ce qui
attire les jeunes sur le fait que ce
soit non seulement médiatisé mais quand
on les fait qu'ils soient ludiques
pourquoi il est dit que c'est que si on
parle de soi stable on va prendre un
exemple comme la théophylline vous êtes
dans une salle c'est fermé ya pas le
vent favorable il n'y a pas de
variations de charge vous devez les de
la charge ce assez stable vous faites de
l'okano à l'eau en eaux vives et où vous
vous lutter contre les éléments de la
nature que vous ne contrôlez pas sain
stable
vous avez un ballon de rugby ça tombe ça
prend toutes les directions
saint stable est loin mais dans la
hauteur de l'instabilité dans fait la
boxe comme
le sport que commander notre collègue
ici on a on a des la tête le corps sur
lequel on travaille
sauf que ces zones sont multipliés de
manière exponentielle avec nous mêmes
parce qu'on a eu des armes on peut faire
appareiller point les pieds les coudes
les genoux on peut et donc du coup je
considère que je pense que l'une des
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles je
vois les parents ramener plus - lagos
sais pas ce qu'il y a quelque chose de
ludique et de développement de la
motricité surtout les qualités physiques
fausse endurance force coordination
souplesse tout ce que vous voulez sur ce
qui est physique et donc huige
c'est ce qui plaît moi c'est ce qui
plaît il fasse ce sport et les bordelais
arrivants effectivement sa discipline
une discipline on a dix qui compterait
entre 30000 et 50000 pratiquants en
france dans la commission française du
mma on a les autres chiffres sur les
autres fédérations la fédération de judo
600 mille licenciés en france selon la
ffj airs karaté 250 2700 en boxe 52
mille licenciés selon le parisien
c'était en 2017 mais dont 60 60 mille
maintenant mais la question qu'on se
pose c'est les 58 donc du coup bien
bientôt autant de pratiquants mma que de
pratiquants de boxe la question qu'on se
pose c'est est-ce que le mma est ce que
c'est la mort annoncée de
du judo par exemple et des autres
fédérations des autres arts martiaux on
a posé cette question dans tous les cas
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un c'est
un sondage
et le résultat c'est 24 5% oui 75 points
5 % non procès a fait tant polémique
quand on voit finalement ce résultat
selon vous fernand lopez
encore une fois de plus la
méconnaissance du système
je sème fédéral en france et du cadre
institutionnel fait qu on avance moins
des choses qui ne sont pas encore la
fération de boxe anglaise
si 60 me licencie ok mais en pratiquant
il ya à peu près 150 mille pratique en
boxe anglaise
ok la filiation l'estimation qu'on a sur
le net ou de 50000 pratiquants parce
qu'on n'a pas encore les indicateurs on
n'a pas de 800 siens et même a donc peut
pas savoir exactement quoi qu'il en soit
si j'étais la fédération de judo et que
je devais faire la publicité de la
fédération internationale de judo
je dirais à des athlètes si vous voulez
meilleurs combattants des mets ma fête
comme honda rossi à la fête
elle a été médaillée d'or aux jeux
olympiques de pékin
guillaume il ya ensuite des virions
palais de retombées économiques on a un
vrai ascenseur social
cette jeune dame elle a terminé jeux
olympiques elle était vendeuse dans un
fast food et au final elle se retrouve
dans le magazine forbes m est un athlète
féminine de l'année 2016 ce qui est
certain c'est que aujourd'hui le mets ma
a pris une ampleur surtout les cinq
continents par ce public jeune justement
où on a le sentiment parfois dans la
mesure où tout est permis
entre guillemets que ça a pu permettre
c'est ça où tout est permis que les
jeunes viennent à ce sport c'est cela
aussi
mais justement un business ba s'est
développée
avec le mma je vous propose de regarder
ce sujet signé clément delcourt juteux
business qu'est le mma en 2016 la
société wmc img rachète pour 4 milliards
de dollars l'ultimate fighting
championship l'organisation américaine
responsable de la majorité des
compétitions à l'époque ufc est la
septième marque de sport la plus
valorisée au niveau mondial et depuis
son économie ne cesse de se développer
avec un impact direct dans les villes
organisant des combats janvier 2020
mcgregor contre ceroni 40 secondes de
combat à peine et ses plus de 86
millions de dollars injectés dans
l'économie de la ville de las vegas ufc
touche aujourd'hui 1,2 milliards de
foyers dans 158 pays et les combats sont
diffusés dans 21 langues différentes en
france alors que la discipline était
encore interdite en estimait au moins
quarante mille le nombre de pratiquants
répartis dans plus de 700 clubs à
travers le pays
côté télévision les audiences sont en
moyenne supérieure à 250 mille
téléspectateurs et devrait continuer
d'évoluer positivement dans les années à
venir
qu'est ce qui va se passer avec cette
information d'égaliser autorisé
normalisée en termes de business il va y
avoir des combats a monté par des
promoteurs
c'est ce que ça se passe déjà je suis ma
casquette de d'entraînement et de
promoteur en tant que responsable des
actions aussi du de la promotion ares a
thing championship
c'est une promotion de vivendi à la
maison vivendi à une a créé cette
société qui est une promotion afro
européenne avec l'intention d'apporter
une qualité de production jamais vu avec
une qualité de cartes encore jamais vues
sur mesure pour poulets poulet 68
millions de français et les africains du
coup on a fait le premier événement à
dakar au sénégal le second se devrait se
faire devait se faire au zénith et on
est passé sur bruxelles et là on
reviendra en france aussitôt que le
cadre décisionnel aux pme train vune
paris bruxelles à l'époque il y avait
luxembourg également
d'où étaient diffusés les les matchs de
mm c'était illégal en france avec combat
sport maintenant c'est rennes c'est avec
le fait que le mma deviennent normalisée
est ce que d'autres grands opérateurs
vont se lancer selon vous dans la
médiatisation de ce sport je pense à
canal+ notamment qui diffuse souvent de
la boxe est ce qu'il va y avoir un match
là dedans et également économiquement
alors si je me permets de répondre
il y a le marché l'us portel c'est un
indicateur très précises sur la santé
d'un sport précisément donc le sportel
marché du sport et de la télévision mais
aussi des nouvelles technologies qui
déroule à monaco depuis trente ans tous
les diffuseurs tous les organisateurs
sont présents et donc un marché on
achète on vend et avant auparavant
pendant des années il y avait des storm
de boxe et jeux vidéo étaient présents
showtime et espn les grands
organisateurs de boxe également donc les
diffuseurs et là ils sont moins présents
le marché du mma se développe parce que
dans ces fameux store d'aujourd'hui les
vendeurs de droit sont très présents et
le stand de l'ufc est impressionnant et
common law on l'avait d'ailleurs au
synthé avec 158 pays à distribuer 20 21
et c'est donc il ya une présence et une
montée en puissance très nette
aujourd'hui sur le marché en france
aujourd'hui il y aura de la concurrence
maintenant les sports de combat ne sont
pas diffusés à 8h30 à 21h on le sait par
expérience les sports de combat c'est à
22h36 sont des sports du soir on diffuse
pas de la boxe ou du mma à midi elles se
rapportent
fernand lopez oui absolument ça rapporte
vous avez vu tout à l'heure on a parlé
de lieux c'est comme la 7e à la plus
connue au monde mais il faut savoir que
en termes de 2,2 marche de progression
si on prend le cas de nike qui a la
manie numéro 1 connu la plus vendeuse au
monde
elle a fait sur l'année 2016 2017 une
plus value
6.4 poussins alors que lui c'est sûr la
même temporalité a fait 233 % c'est vous
dire la manière exponentielle dont le
marché du mma évolué on sait aujourd'hui
que les indicateurs montrent que les
télévisions marche bien lui et stéphane
pasquier la plateforme de lui et si ça
doit intéresser le bio ça devrait
devenir olympique un jour le même
absolument je n'ai aucun doute là dessus
je pense que comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure il ya un certain nombre de
valeurs et de la belle qu'on doit avoir
pour pouvoir rentrer aussi aussi une
affaire de la belle le coc comme le
dopage c'est du label et je pense que
aujourd'hui passer la barrière de ce
qu'on ne connaît pas
quand rentrer à l'intérieur et qu'on
voit le système de la protection
médicale qu'on met sur le sur le mma
qu'on voit le système de l'antidopage
qu'on met dessus qu'on va le système de
la prise en main de la bête on a il n'y
a pas de raison qui est pas de qu'on ne
soit pas
aussi voilà en tout cas aux jeux
olympiques sur les prochaines années
arup avant je serai plus prudent je
serai plus prudent parce qu'on sait que
c'est ou est très sensible au sens
pourquoi la boxe a été en danger au delà
des combines entre guillemets des
décisions scandaleuses c'est que le sang
a toujours choqué les membres du cio
on n'aime pas mais justement il n'y a
pas là on ne parle pas de sens avec eux
ce qu'on ne sait pas ce que le mma une
fédération internationale amateur et le
mma materia pas le sans appel il ya deux
trois coups bien le boxeur qui fait un
ascenseur jusqu il descend une fois on
ne compte pas le stop toute une étape
absolument donc il ya une vraie il ya
une vraie en marge de ce qu'ils on
connaît les 900 ce qu'on connaît de la
compétition de haut niveau
il ya vraiment 91% des personnes qui
font du cinéma amateur avec une voix
organisation et cette organisation-là le
même en amateur qui la dernière
compétition s'est passée les champions
du monde au bahreïn où la prochaine c1
las vegas cette compétition elle de
prendre des centaines des pays qui vont
avec et on est prêt avec cette
compétition je voulais essayer
voilà elle sera aux jo la question est
de savoir si lors de la fin parlons donc
peut-être le même à ogero on verra quand
en tous les cas merci messieurs d'être
revenue sur ce plateau pour parler de ce
thème donc le mma autorisée en france
fernand lopez
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau donc
entraîneur le plus coté de france dans
cette discipline et jean philippe lustyk
la voie de la boxe en france auteur du
grand livre de la boxe aux éditions
marabout merci beaucoup monsieur dont on
se retrouve évidemment la semaine
prochaine pour un autre thème d'ici là
vous pouvez revoir
évidemment cet autre match en podcast ou
en replay sur arte france pointé veneman
[Musique]